hello everybody and welcome to let's
play dead space okay I know a lot of you
have asked me to do this so it was $5.00
on Steam this and dead space 2 or 5
dollars so I scooped them both up so get
ready to go for it I've noticed that
these mouse controls are weird
oh man doggies do it cuz I'm so brave
and smart um ass to medium I'm tougher
than easy not quite so tough for hard
though okay we're ready
loading up that's cool what's that zoom
what has happened shock point yeah Oh
long loading cringes you want me to do
something entertaining wait look at me
okay
okay this is cool so far
USD kellian on route to agus system
primary mission Isaac Clark
Kendra Daniels Zach Hammond locate
mining vessel USGS amaura diagnosing
repair communication blackout okay it's
me hello I wish I could talk to you
hi I'm sorry oh it's okay I'm sorry
about everything
oh it's all right oh hello
so frog what's happening strange little
thing oh hang on
damn it how many times you watch that
thing I totally forgot I did not turn
down the audio cuz I'm an idiot
I couldn't hear me hear me at all ah
down there ha ha hey these mouseketools
are awful by the way awful awful awful
get down there good good
down there leave that a little bit up
top toes on here we go okay huh no get
get out of here gotta get back to the
game cept Hanzel resume okay yes you
really miss her all better now I'm a
professional game player grab points
were on board a useful phone as well to
do
you know so far syncing our orbit now I
know that voice deep space mining is a
lucrative business miss Daniels each
seventies a goldmine a coil respect yes
cobalt silicon osmium uh-huh I know what
those are Hera she meshes we have visual
contact there she is
alright so that's a she Maura
impressive none of your SDG is Shimura
biggest planet record in her class yeah
ain't nothing and it looks like they
like crack planets see any running
lights corporal take us in closer and
hailed them and stay clear that debris
field Ray had to fix their ship not the
other way around
you so clever man USG Ishimura this is
the emergency maintenance team of the
USG kellian responding to your distress
call come in easy Maura that's the voice
actor from I know he's from a lot of
downs but it's loud yes we know he was
the signal most recently he was in he
place the the Lewis Master named
Spartacus
he's black I don't wanted these things
you'd think with a thousand people on
board someone would pick up the phone
maybe they're all dead
probably hence the name what is that
it's a busted array like we thought
sounds like they're having problems with
their encoder sounds looking a statistic
and I can fix it 48 hours max
all right you're the lady take us in
Missy well I think I should look around
little gravity tethers engaged automatic
docking procedures that go all right
long intro uh-oh
who's only a matter of time until
something happened what happened switch
to manual now okay seems like a bad idea
to go in when your ships ripping apart
of course so much for the we're here to
fix the airship not ours business Sam
okay yeah I'm fine
I'll just saved our asses miss Daniels
if we had aborted at that speed and
distance would have smashed right into
this idea Maura Yeah right idle down
let's get to work
corporal report oh boy I'm not getting
any readings from the port oh I almost
saw main characters face it'll take some
time to fire I think that happens better
get some extra hands from flight deck to
help out hello baby
how you doing I'm thinking of everyone's
rig with the ship okay we're done clean
bill of health for everyone okay all
right well you did we're gonna jail
it'll bar went up everything out I'm
guessing that's my health bar so how do
you know ugly
sorry you you're not you're not baby
you're not so ugly you beautiful I don't
know if I'm ugly or not but no what am I
saying I'm handsome as hell look at me
oh oh oh controls all these controls are
funky whoa good run yes like in every
other game it exists it's okay
Lissa's all med back gimme pick it up
pick it up pick it up hang on did I get
it Hey ah yeah ah look at me go oh don't
look at me go I'm not going that way
hello baby
did you miss me oh yeah I love watching
you go away unbelievable I screwed up
that line real bad it's okay I'll
protect you
not anymore yeah also huh cows down
everywhere Isaac go be an active Oh fat
what door that door he pick it up pick
it up pick it up pick it up I'm doing
something to it
Hey pick it up I don't know uh II button
oh this looks dangerous ah boxes green
glowing boxes who says no can't use it
hello unlocked roof boop boop boop
Oh blood everywhere always a good sign
hello guy what's this alright there's
nobody here there's no way cuz there's
old dead from the blood maybe
which one Isaac login is huge oh the one
I was just at I'm an idiot I'm an idiot
okay I'm an idiot everyone relaxed
holiday if I can okay you already
operate come on I'm using it Oh get that
computer this place I'm trying use it
okay
locator B oh no the pointing right to it
that's gonna be useful okay look at it
be map screen M oh so no actual menu
okay so I'm get out of get a tabbed
excellent objective screen Jay huh
remover looks like it's a bad shape I
was like the journal from amnesia okay
our shuttle is going need extensive
repairs where the hell is a flight group
dead all did huh okay hey good e he use
it you just do Padang okay there we go
look good no that's it the Tran systems
offline get around gonna be difficult
yep as always as she's be flung again
that's a start hmm Oh what the hell was
I no automatic quarantine must have
tripped on the filtration system we
started oh yeah that somebody right back
what was that did you hear that oh oh
dude dude dude dude dude there's a dude
cut yeah yep you're dead
yep you're dead you're dead
oh don't don't even try it don't even
come in here ha ha ha
don't here to tell me twice Guinea
kidding kidding kidding
what where oh here sorry ha ha good get
it use it unit get it good ha ha ha
[ __ ] you ah ok good start
um I heard this game wasn't that scary
is all wrong mmm ok huh
hello well oh I got a gun oh shoot the
limbs off enemies for extra damage help
punch footstone Oh
oh yeah foots to hos foots dumb f save
space I can't jump about E I know these
are boxes come on mom
I know these are boxes to open up ah
never mind
what do they do
okay open up open up this thing I got
shoot it there we go okay oh haha oh
yeah Oh [ __ ] of fu Oh Oh God out of
here sorry buddy
I know you were banging on that door a
long time I just this it's a little too
late oh you look yeah you don't look so
bad you're not even wounded what the
hell man
what a wimp okay I gotta cut it here
thank you guys so much for watching that
was a bit of a a good start I suppose so
thank you guys so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
part
bye bye